thank you
again uh good morning ladies and
gentlemen welcome to this first internal
oversight and scrutiny meeting of this
new Administration
um before uh we start on the agenda I'm
going to begin by going around a room
and asking uh members to introduce
themselves and uh just say who they are
if I start with myself uh I'm Simon
Newton I am the district councilor for
winkley Ward I have sat in the last
Administration on both internal and
external oversight and scrutiny
and I was a member of the working group
which uh re-crafted the way that we
present the quarterly business return
um
East
I'm James craigie for the Biddeford East
Wards freshly elected uh ready to get
going
I'm Ian Harper and I'm an independent
member
yeah sorry oh here we go I'm Wendy
Lovell newly elected to Orchard Hill
I'm councilor Doug Smith representing
great Torrington
um councilor Chris bright representing
great Torrington first time sitting on
the committee
hi I'm Claire Hodson I represent
Westward Ho as a parish counselor and
also as a district councilor
and if I come to the uh offices on my
right
hello I'm Steve Hurst I'm the chief
executive at Torres District Council
hi my name is David Hayes I'm the
finance manager in section 151 officer
at Torres District Council
morning I'm John wilter I'm a strategy
performance and ICT manager at torridge
good well that's the introductions uh
underway
moving to the agenda first of all
um when can we have apologies for
absence
Hunkin with councilor Smith substituting
councilor bushby councilor inch and Mr
Stephen dengate independent member
thank you very much
we are just to confirm we are core it
even though we have quite a lot of
members away today
moving on the agenda and I would uh
you've gotten a message about please
press your microphone otherwise it uh
can't be picked up by the YouTube
recording
um
moving on the agenda now
um first of all the minutes the last
meeting from the 16th of March that was
of course a meeting held by the previous
committee and therefore we can note
those minutes but it is not for us to
vote on them because there is nobody
here able to do so
um
so I will if you've had a look at those
we will just quickly go through them by
Page
on as shown page three
page four
speak up if you've got a question or
comment page five
Page Six
page seven
yes yeah just a couple of questions
the homeless strategy
I noticed that we had that quite a few
well good good year ago that um Jane
Janet Williams said it was ready we're
still waiting for it
and the other one as well on that one is
uh
head of community is is the five hundred
thousand pounds is that arrived yet
from the visit from the uh from the
government which page we're looking at
on we're looking at page six yeah page
six and it's Midway down yeah
it's page 22 the themes two
we
so the rural Prosperity fund yes we've
received uh approval of the council's
use of that fund so that's that's in
place on the homeless Society yes uh
start by you are correct
um obviously we had a restructure within
the team as well
and the homeless team are now reporting
directly to Stacy Doria head of legal
and governance and we'll be chatting
with the lead and Deputy leader later
around a housing strategy it would
probably make sense to incorporate the
house the homelessness strategy into one
single document I know it's on the
forward plan and when we have a
discussion later we'll determine
when that should come back
that'd be 500.
that really should be 500 000 yes sorry
yes
there's a typing mistake on on the
minutes it should read 500 000 not 50
000.
minor detail
s
Conan yeah yes
what we we've got an absence of an
overall over arching strategy we have
been dealing with the the homelessness
crisis so we've been working on projects
to bring Sally house into occupation uh
we've had grant funding from the
government to put housing pods in place
which we do in so we've been tackling
the problem in advance of having a
strategic document because that's what
it was action that was needed to be done
to deal with the problem and we will be
pulling together a strategic document
foreign
what a strategic document is high level
our key consideration is tackling the
financial problems the council has in
funding temporary accommodation so what
you've just suggested is what we're
already doing finding areas for suitable
temporary accommodation
the principles of the strategy is to
reduce homelessness reduce temporary
accommodation and to reduce the
financial impact on the council's budget
they're either high level
strategic things that are having the
greatest level of impact
Peter thanks for that week we we will be
coming back because the strategy will be
appearing in in our forward plan I mean
we you know it hasn't been lost uh and
we we are we are we will be chasing it
um
we can but note those minutes and take
no further action on that moving to the
action list that is currently blank for
um this um this committee
um public contributions uh I'm told
there are none is that correct
yes
um Declarations of Interest
members as always it is incumbent upon
yourselves please to declare if you have
an interest uh be it personal financial
whatever and you are all aware of the
requirement to do so I have no urgent
matters to bring forward
um and we're going to start and I've
asked John Walters to put together a
short presentation for our benefit and
for the benefit of anybody who may be
watching as well which is an
introduction to internal
scrutiny at torridge
I.E what is it that we're meant to be
doing and how would we do it
um John
foreign
[Music]
sorry about that we just had to make
sure that this was broadcasting properly
so as you say as you say there's a
um a brief introduction to the scrutiny
process so I'm going to run through a
few slides
um and then we're happy to take some
questions David we'll do a few as well
with um with regard to the qbr just to
give you a little feel for it before we
go into the detail and we've agreed that
I will chip in every now and then
absolutely
so there are some legit
okay so it's on my screen and it's not
on there why is that
okay
can you see a difference like Kirsty
now we've only got the introduction
slide
okay
now it's not the right
it's not going forward
do you want me have you got other slides
on there do you want me to send you this
one to pull up
sorry chair not
professional Watson recorded
on the road that shouldn't have been
given
thanks for a couple hunkins chair of
external tribal also reported in and was
refused can you explain church and work
as a such a same situation should arise
I'm the Deferred
and then I'll then I'll apply an
interpretation
well ordinarily is similar to other
things the chair of internal scrutiny
made that first call in so that and it's
uh and it was in relation to the funding
aspect and the funding aspect is a
function of internal overview and
scrutiny rather than the the performance
and value for money aspect of what the
funding is being used for which would be
an external overview and scrutiny
function so because it was in relation
to the budget and the funding that's an
internal scrutiny uh role and
responsibility and councilor Watson had
called it in first
10 out of 10 good response
if counselor kottle hankin had called it
in to ask how the money at the plow was
being used for then that would have been
a different call in
because that's the external use of the
council's funding so that would be a
role of that committee I know there's
some gray areas and it does get
sometimes complex and confusion when we
have two external scrutiny committees
but that's the the base and basic
principles of how the the split is
achieved
transcription
it wasn't done I'd have to read the the
precise wording of what was being
submitted we're talking about
theoretical things so we could sit here
and talk about that all morning so
that is a that's a hypothetical
hypothetical situation because as you
know as you know councilor Pennington we
are currently working on the evaluation
of social value and being able to to
quantify social value and that is
something that we will be taking forward
but at the moment we can't do it so it
would it would have been a a meaningless
exercise in that sense but I think the
right decision was arrived at at the end
anyway so there's no problem
well of course
thank you chair
um this is the extract and I know you
want me to read it all but this is the
extract um of the terms of reference
functional responsibilities part three
chapter one so that just goes um shows
you know what and how
um uh the operation of the internal
scrutiny
um and we've we've talked about it it's
reviewing scrutinized decisions made
um
exercise any functions relating to the
resources as Steve was saying you know
the resources land and finance of the
council monitor the overall budget
um
question members and officers and and
staff Etc so that's a basic overview and
it is in your Constitution so you guys
can can refer to it so if we go to the
next one please
so uh just a few more slides for me
um ways of working as we said before
it's holding the leader uh committee
members to encounter meetings
um last year the leader did come along
with the chief executive
um and answer some questions on a
subject
of of interest to the committee at the
occasional call-in
um holding up appropriate officers and
partners and the partners bit would be
the external side of it
comparing performance against Plans and
budget undertaking specific reviews as a
chair mentioned previously we looked at
the whole qbr last time and and then
also looking at statistics and
benchmarking against similar authorities
um if you go to the next slide please
so work programming opportunities
um you know it's it's about the the
coordination with corporate processes so
it's linking in with other things that
the council are doing use of forward
plans are important
the reason why you start looking at
things you know you're looking at
performance data you're looking at
benchmarking you may be looking at
public views on certain things that are
going on
um and a lot of the guidance says it's
for scrutiny to look at where it can add
value you know it it
um
and the the criteria strategic
priorities The Wider impact major spend
major sources of complaint under
performance public concern and you know
the the stuff that the um scrutiny
Network say is is trying to avoid that
pet issue uh thing and coming coming
forward it is looking at making that
real difference
so if you like to go to the next slide
please this is and again you won't see
read this very well on the slide but I
can assure you'll get emailed this
um after the meeting this is something
that the chairs asked me to produce it's
the internal ons uh committee's previous
year's work program so we've gone back
uh four years so it gives you an idea of
everything that the internal scrutiny
has looked at over the last four years
and the chair is going to ask or has
asked me to produce this we're going to
circulate it to members after the
meeting
and I'm not sure if I'm allowed to use
the word homework but that was uh the
term that the chair you did mention to
me sorry chair but it will be for the
next meeting when you start looking at
developing your your forward plan in
some detail you've got a little bit of
background of what's been looked at
previously and and kind of
um you know what's happened so so that's
there for you
um
to look at if you go to the the next
slide please so this is
um the qbr
um this David do you want to take this
one do you want me just uh yeah thank
you so this is the qbr this this is kind
of
um when when you looked at the previous
slides that we mentioned about the
Performance Management the finances and
all of that this is really the main
document the main function of this
committee is looking at and and studying
this piece of this document
um it does monitor the council's
finances and the performance data it was
thoroughly reviewed in 2021 and we set
up a task and finish group
um we looked at the existing qbr we
aligned uh the the new one to the our
strategic plan we made sure that the
actions aligned we made sure it was
easier to read
um
we
completely
um
re-structured it
um and I suppose it's a good time for me
to say
this that piece of work was
um looked at by the LGA and I was asked
to do a presentation to the LGA and some
other councils to show the work of this
task and finish group and how it worked
through
transforming from the previous qbr into
the new one and actually how it's
structured now with the information and
the wording that counselor really wants
and really understand
to kind of previous ones so that went
down really well with the LGA and some
other councilors and councils shall I
say I'll just jump in there John
we use the premise that if something is
not understandable then it's not worth
the paper it's written on and the and
also
you've got to identify the target
audience who you're wanting to read it
we started with a very with a baseline
of elected councilors as a starter and
hopefully more widely than that people
who have a an in the general public who
have an interest in the the workings and
the performance of the council and we
found we had a document which was
unintelligible to anybody who was not a
real
enthusiastic anorak in the area and as
and as a result we rewrote it in a form
which
is still not perfect and I will be
during the time looking to see how it
can be tweaked or areas which don't
quite uh run properly but hopefully that
is where we came from trying to produce
something that anybody could pick up and
see where we were coming from and relate
what we'd said that we wanted to achieve
and how we were achieving it was
actually also a good
amount of comparison in it so you could
look at performance over a number of
years sorry John on you go
thank you chair
um and the other thing is just a couple
of more bullet points to to say the
thing that um the committee were really
keen on but also that went really down
well with the LGA and the other councils
was the the bit about actually sending
out the qbr in advance of the agenda
asking for questions in advance so that
actually
that allowed
um for the committee and and the offices
to provide a fuller response to the
committee it stops the don't know it
committee or having to wait to the next
meeting for the answer it was a the um
one of the councils
um actually said to me they saw that as
a more strategic route with having the
questions and the answers kind of at the
meeting rather than kind of you know ad
hoc at the meeting so that would that
went down really well so um
that's kind of where we are at the
moment
um there's a next slide please States
Kirsty
um
this this is the the new look
um you've all seen it you've all had it
in in your in your packs and and you'll
see the the thing I'll add is what was
agreed was that it is Sentai to all
cancer councilors in advance not just
the committee so actually we we if
possible we want to encourage all input
and everybody has the opportunity to
raise questions in advance if they wish
um so that's what what's done
um
so it's a new format it is landscape if
you go to the next slide please we do
provide a highlights page
um which is there and and you guys would
have seen this in in a document that's
previously been circulated and then if
you go to the next slide please
um
David do you want to just give a little
bit of context of some of the the
finance bits I know we're going into the
detail in a minute but just kind of
where we got to
yeah so
so there's a few
Finance slides included in the qbr and
the one in front of you there is
actually the income feed and charges
income not all the fees in charge but
the main ones
and there's a
a little bit of a narrative on the side
and says if we're up on income why are
we up on income if we're down on income
while we're down on income
um so that's just one slide and at the
bottom there is a slide on our
expenditure and basically staff related
costs the budget where we are and what
the establishment but they're probably
more pertinently would be on the right
hand side there is actually see the
vacancies so you know an issue we've got
at the moment is Staff retention and
Recruitment and if that figure starts
going up you that's an understanding as
to why certain performers matters might
be challenging for the council so that
so there's lots of different there's
about five or six
slides that relate to finance is this
yeah that's one that's well so that
one's the income one
this one is just uh gives you the I'm
going to go through this later so I
won't go through this now this is what
where's it what's the outturn for the
council and on one side you've got the
oldest fence on one side you've got the
under spending list not everyone but
it's list the major contributors to
where the council is next one Kirsty
please
and then this one's a this relates to
the proof slide which just gives a
little bit more detail and narrative a
bit more verbal explanation of the key
variances up or down next one please
then we're telling you that when our
money's invested so the council at any
one time holds 15 20 million pounds in
short-term treasury deposits
um so on this one it's showing you that
we've got 15 million pounds on charts
short-term treasury deposits how long
for what the rates are who they're with
and also a snapshot of what's in the
council's current accounts so when this
was done a physical first to ask there's
21 million pounds in which
Council has between short-term treasury
deposits and on our current account next
slide Kirsten
this one is showing you about the
capital
the budget for the capital the budget it
shows there isn't the total budget for
Capital it's the budget for Capital from
either previous years or the current
year what's been spent
um and then on the right hand side it's
got the total Capital program and then
in the boxes underneath there's a little
bit of narrative so a narrative might
say oh we've got a big budget for
property and infrastructure but we
haven't purchased a site for the
environment Center we haven't started
building so that's why Capital expansion
in that area is down next one Kirsten
and then this one is a summary of the
reserves that the council holds what the
four where there's been any movement on
them
um
that's that's basically it really and if
you know somewhere I can't read any of
yourself but it looks like about 16
million at the bottom that actually
approximates to how much we've got in
short-term treasury departure so it's
mostly our reserves are backed by cash
so that's the reason we've got money in
short-term treasury projects because
we've got reserves uh I think that's
probably all the finance
um pages
and just very quickly then this this is
just to show you that um kind of it
works from left to right
um you've got your strategic priority
um
Doug do you have a question sorry I
missed it
um
yeah we've got a treasury management
policy which determines how officers in
the finance team cooperate when they
place and the agreement was it came
within 0.2 percentage points
so if we can get it at 4.5 and we could
do ethical at 4.3
go with the ethical
that's what the policy is the policy is
um
approved by Council that is approved by
full Council so it was and what we've
found is we're basically not getting
uh there's none out there that meet the
criteria being close enough to what we
can get on
um the General market you know a full
Council made a decision to change that
percentage then that treasury management
you might see something different we've
had about
well it's 0.2 percent
one fifth of one percent
yeah I can ask
um what's what's the closest kind of
ethical you know how far away is the
ethical from current standing like or is
it point two is actually nowhere near
where Africa even is I don't I don't
know to be honest I don't know but
actually from this is sorry this is
probably why if you ask questions in
advance it's a good thing because I
could have had the answer ready I don't
know it's only just come from a
presentation not being because
I know at the moment it's actually
difficult from Peter who's a deputy
section more Firefox who deals with this
is finding anybody actually offering it
so I don't think that we're missing out
by small percentages it's actually
finding availability of people doing it
yeah thank you just yeah only a very a
couple of really quick um slides now
chair um this is just a show it works
from left to right showing the Strategic
priority the actions that we've got in a
strategic plan and then from the
officers concerned that the kind of the
progress and the overall position so
that that shows everything kind of goes
from left to right so that that kind of
shows um you um how it works and if you
have go to the next slide please
um for each of them as well there are
some key performance indicators so
they're all all on there as well and
that gives you the total today and the
same time
um last year and they're ragged red
Amber green depending on the performance
and there are some notes
um particularly um if there's uh
performances Amber or red will put in um
some notes from the officers to say why
um if you go to the next slide I just
want to kind of there's a few what what
the committee's also decided to do
um in the previous qbr there was lots
and lots of information of
um kind of previous
um data and and the members there said
actually
um it took away from the actual current
data they didn't want to lose uh the
previous data but they didn't need it
every month so what they asked officers
to do was to produce an annual Trend
analysis so what that does is uh it's
published alongside qbr4 each year so
it's the end of year one you've got it
in your packs today
um it gives
um the
um
measures that are in the qbr but it also
gives some extra measures that probably
will only come out on a yearly basis
again it reads some
um left to right in day order it gives a
minimum of six years data where we've
got it
the target is against current year
actual
um and it produces a trend graph so if
we go to the next slide you'll see what
I mean and it has been on your so
there's a finance page here so this will
show you what
the over the last five five six years or
whatever it is on on the screen how the
finances
um have moved how the income because
this is your income bit and you'll see
uh the trend a bar chart on the right
hand side just gives you a snapshot and
that that is produced by
um the system and it's um it's meant for
you to give you a little bit of oh
what's that it may seem a little bit out
of sync because the the the the variance
is maybe small but that's kind of the
point it's it's just there to give you
that initial let's have a little look at
the data behind the graph so go to next
slide please
um there's some these are some
performance ones
um so you'll see um some performance
ones and again it's um
when I showed this to the LGA and and
those other councils they're really
impressed with this document they
thought it was really really clear
really interesting and it gives officers
as well as members
um that um look at if there is a trend
that they should be concerned about or
actually even if it is not necessarily
bad Trend it could be a good Trend you
know is there something that's happening
um uh you know out there that that is
affecting affecting performance or
income so if we go to the next slide
please
um that's just the last one just to show
um some more you have got the document
if you go to the next slide
that's kind of a very brief overview
from from me I'm sorry I kind of shot
through it and with the technical
difficulties at the start uh happy to
answer any questions but uh David will
be going through the the qbr in more
detail on your agenda that's just a an
outline of
um kind of the role of scrutiny and um
kind of our main work program thank you
Joe
John thank you for that I just summarize
with a couple of takeaways from that
sat here we are backed by legal legal
Authority this isn't just a sort of an
informal thing that torridge thought
they'd put together the oversight and
scrutiny function as you saw is backed
by a number of different legal positions
our requirement is to be impartial
and independent with a small eye
and this isn't the forum for you to or
for any of us to bring our personal
thing that that from our Ward
particularly we are strategic we are
overarching on
um the business of the council and the
performance of the council and therefore
please try to keep it there it is it is
always tempting to want to bring your
own particular thing that that applies
just to your your area well if it's
something that actually has relevance
district-wide well that's different but
please
be cautious on that call in I would urge
people to use sparingly
um it is an exception rather than a rule
um doesn't mean that it can't be used um
but it's very easy for somebody to put a
hand up Tower I want to call that in
because I don't like it well
calling needs to be on the basis
um that uh
of principle and not just on personal
View
our work is a mix of periodic review
programmed like the quarterly Business
Report funnily enough comes along
quarterly
and various other things that we will
look on at a regular basis and then look
at things
by exception for a specific reason
because something is raised that is
concerned
the qbr is our absolute bread and butter
and I would ask all councilors here on
the committee you really need to be into
that document in detail and I would
encourage at the moment you'll have seen
an I've been away so I'm as guilty as
anybody else the the the only person
only people who submitted questions are
our two independent members this time
around Stephen and Ian
um we need to get back to counselors
also
putting in questions on it please if you
have a question and has been pointed out
by Steve and by by David that
now is not the time for the cold call
um or or the no notice question because
officers invariably quite reasonably
don't have the detail in order to be
able to answer it if you actually put a
question in in advance uh on the qbr
they've got the opportunity to pass it
to the relevant expert and we'll get a
properly informed answer
um
the qbr is always up to be able to be
tweaked if we see every period of time
um
and our business in the qbr is very much
as John was just reiterating there
we're looking at trends
and Trends tell you and and if if
something changes then red lights start
to flash and there's a reason for it and
we have a traffic light system and
hopefully it it will help us as we go
through so moving on that was just I
wanted to to go through that what I
didn't do was
um an agreement between the agenda items
part one and two there are no part two
items in this meeting so we can move on
item number nine
straight uh to the business is qbr4 and
the end of year Trend summary
um
David your very last presentation to
let's hope Kirsty got the slides
sorry just uh correct John there I'm not
going to go through a detailed uh Page
by Page analysis of the cube out I'm
just going to focus a bit narrowly on
the finance ones
um for this meeting
so what I want to slide up there says
the headline we've got a headlines draft
surplus of 833
000. and then there's a big butt so any
members earlier who remembers of the
Council on the previous administration
earlier on the year will be somewhat
surprised at that because I was making
some more dire projections
however what sort of reasons are bought
is the Surplus is after utilizing 927
000 pounds from Reserves so we budgeted
at the start of the year so this is for
more for the benefit of new members at
the start of the council budgeted to use
374 000 pounds from reserves to balance
the reserve we call the transitioning
Government funding Reserve
so we're actually budgeting to make a
loss of 374
000 and a quarter two so that'll be a
September 2022.
um we what we're in financial
predicament so we've scoured through all
various reserves that we didn't think
there was a real intimate need for and
we used to release them back into the
revenue budget so 553 000. so we hadn't
used reserve the council would have had
a deficit of 94 000.
the Surplus is provisional because we're
still awaiting final figures from Active
touch but I don't expect there to be any
material difference to the out and
there's some last minute adjustments
relating to partial vat claim but I
don't see making a great deal of
difference
however the surface does contain some
non-recurrent favorable movements and
the biggest one though is council tax
Annex grant funding
and essentially we've been sharing this
funding to help us and its grant funding
with our preceptors for I think now five
six years and then it came out in the
last settlement that that is a grant
just for us and not meant to be shared
with his preset doesn't seem to actually
make a greater logical sense however
that is the ruling so that 396 000 is
clawback of five years worth of grant
funding that we've shared with our
preceptors so of course that won't
happen next year and we budgeted for
receiving the council tax Annex ground
which actually has been core funded
within the revenue support settlement
there was a settlements of outstanding
Leisure so we set aside money for the
sorting out our contractual arrangements
with the previous operator of our
Leisure Center um 1610 and that's a
favorable boot of 59 000. I've also had
some Grant income for land charges for
movement of data to the valuation office
so that slide is saying yes we've made a
surplus but we hadn't released one
different reserves we would have had a
deficit and there's a few big-ish and
particularly one big item of
non-recurrent which won't occur next
year and next slide please go step
so
previously when I went through as I said
that this is one of the slides that you
would get in the cube your heart so it
gives you the big variances at the top
of the adverse variances and below the
significant favorable variances so
anybody who's been on the previous
administration will be no surprised what
the top variance is there that's our
expenditure overspend on temporary
accommodation that's not the expenditure
that's our overspend on temporary
accommodation
and the reasons are well documented we
can't find sustainable sentences for
people so they stay in temporary
accommodation for extended period of
time cost to the council as Steve
mentioned earlier on we are trying to
secure more
hostile accommodation pods accommodation
we're expanding our perhaps that's a
least accommodation to try and mitigate
the financial impact
and then in a big bunch at 450 000
General inflation fuel utilities we have
contracts which are linked to
information such as contract cleaning
such as our security contract and
insurance and particularly Insurance the
premium is linked to the cost of
rebuilding premises so as inflation goes
up and the cost of rebuilding goes up
that increases the cost of our insurance
and staff costs and there's a few things
here is primarily on 2022-23 we had a
budget provision for the pay award and
the payoff the pay award that came to be
was vastly in excess of that so that
added a lot of additional cost to the
council so that's 420 000. and then some
time and issues regarding business rates
and covid-19 additional restrictions
business rate relief and payments into
the Devon business pool
so what were the key favorable variances
well first off it's not really a
favorable variance when you're taking
money out of Reserve so in terms of the
revenue budget it is but from the
council's perspective we had money sets
out of reserves and we're throwing that
into the revenue budgets to get them
into balance
um if you've all heard about the recent
interest rise and interest rates and
that means we can make more on the
treasury uh childhood treasury Republic
so mate and we made 523
000 so it's very significant and I'm
going to come to that later on for the
impact for next year
um obviously the non-recurrent saving of
396 000 for the council tax Annex grant
that we were incorrectly sharing with
our preceptor colleagues
um
now this is the one which it will seem
odd to people particularly new members
we've got um a surplus of basically 460
000 on Grant income from government so
we get Grant income as part of this
General government settlement and that's
announced original sentence announced in
December and then gets firmed up in
January so the revenue support Grant new
homes bonus lower to Services Grant Etc
but we've received various amounts of
grant funding during the course of the
Year from central government which
wasn't announced when we did the
settlement
and a lot of these grants have been
giving us money or doing things like
paying household support payments uh
also there's some residual grant money
we've got for doing post verification
payments for covert so the covert grants
have been paid out in previous years but
then we've got to provide additional
information to bade which is the
Department of Business and Enterprise
um so they can check that there's not
been fraud in the administration there
was covered grants so we've been getting
money for doing that we're not really
incurred extra costs we're just to
incurred extra workload for existing
members of staff
so that's quite an exceptional year to
get that amount of on budgeted Grant
income there are some offsetting costs
but not anywhere near that that's done
planning income with the third 2022 was
the third year of exceptional levels of
planning income
um basically we've had one million
pounds for the last three years previous
to that we used to average about 500 to
600 000.
uh the next one it shows as a favorable
various variance but actually I think
more pertinent would have to say that's
actually a more worrying variance
we've we have a vacancy Target of four
hundred thousand pounds and we've
exceeded that by 139 000 well that's
reflecting the difficulty we've got in
filling vacancies primarily so that's
not necessarily a good news story
and we got additional information from
car park and virtual access to Northern
boroughs okay next slide please
so
you won't all you won't get this on a
normal cube out but just for maybe for
the year ahead is just to give you some
flavor of where look at some of the
favorable and adverse appearances I
thought well what's going to happen in
2023-24
uh the repurposing of reserves well that
was a one-off we went through we scored
all the reserves and saw what we could
put through to balance the 2022-23
budgets so that's a one-up
interest receivable I want to say likely
to be higher I think I really should
have put certainly going to be higher
and I think that could actually be
um
we increase the budget I think we could
easily exceed the budget by 500 000
pounds depends how quickly we spend the
capital program in the environment
Center but interest rates have gone up
since we've set the budget
and just giving out we get about 35 000
pounds every month just on our current
account
so I suspect interest money from
treasury short-term treasury reposits I
think we could be looking at four to
five hundred thousand pounds above
budget
non-settlement Grant income I suspect
it'd be lower but I'm almost certain
there's going to be some
because I suspect we'll get further
funding for the
um cost of living crisis and there's
probably other government initiatives
which come our way
that we don't know about at this point
in time and we'll get some grant funding
we'll incur some costs on them sometimes
we won't and sometimes the reason we
don't incur cost is simply the work
that's required involves people with
experience and knowledge and you can't
simply go out to the marketplace and get
them at short notice it unfortunately
does fall on existing stuff the council
tax Annex grant that is a one-off so we
won't get that next year planning income
probably 200 000 I don't know what we'll
do next year on that I've been being
personalized I think it might drop down
a little bit but I'm really in the dark
the vacancy savings over and above four
hundred thousand I strongly suspect that
will be higher next year
as much as anything because one
pay your ward has gone up so the cost of
staff is increased but I don't see any
immediate uh Improvement in the
um it's an over market so it's about
vacancies will continue to be difficult
to fill rental income from this is
primarily from our commercial estate I
suspect that'll be roughly the same
car parking and boroughs access I
suspect that'd be similar we are
dependent however on how good a summer
is we do have some of our car parking is
related to holiday season and the
weather
homelessness I know it's trying to get
more
um hostile accommodation or housing pods
more privately sectored Leasing Property
um but I don't see any decline an
increase in the privately set privately
rented accommodation so I suspect that
overspend will be what we haven't always
been this year because we've increased
the budget but I expect the expenditure
levels to be very similar
staff costs we're already 200 000 behind
the ball because the current employers
offer is 200 000 more than we had in
budget and increasingly we're having to
use agency staff at very enhanced rate
to cover vacancies so I strongly suspect
that our staff costs and agency spend
will be higher next year
premises which is utilities like gas
electric water
I'm expecting that probably to be
similar transport fuel
vehicle parts I expect that to be
similar without have increased the
budget has been a little bit of a drop
off on fuel so we might make some so
over there and the business rate income
I'm expecting that not to be such a
factor
so we're trying to get from there is
there's quite a lot of big variables out
there
um
at the moment I think going into the
year ahead the female I expect to see
will be yours certainly the next the
first qbr one that comes to you you
should be expecting to see four or five
hundred thousand over above Budget car
interest receivable and I would expect
to see
um additional costs on staff and agency
in particular planning income I don't
know and homelessness obviously will be
a key Focus whilst we've increased the
budget we still want to keep a handle on
it and ideal at some point reduce the
expenditure that we've got on it but I
think that's a long haul I don't think
there's a quick fix on homelessness with
the council there may be some benefits
on fuel because I think we've we've
increased the budget with the fuel cost
I think the fuel cost of ease does
somewhat so there may be some variances
uh
um that's all I was going to do is
really on the qbr draft out soon so the
key message is yes you can see a big
headline figure of an understanding fit
free but bear in mind we've taken 900
000 out of reserves to get to there and
there's a couple of one-offs which won't
be repeated in 23 24 but in 23 24
interest receivable will be a big ticket
item for the council into favorable and
I suspect staff costs an agency costs
will be a challenge for the council
David
as always thank you so much for that and
uh We've um as we heard last night of uh
especially for new councilors we've
we've we've been very privileged to to
have
David's uh candid and often
um
um candid interpretation of
um where we are financially
um and um we are all much a richer for
it so thank you
um excuse the plan
um
John are you are we with regards I
apologize first time Grant with regard
to going through the rest of the qbr
um do we go do you think we go straight
to questions or we actually run through
them not normally care you would um ask
if there's any questions for David's bit
and then instead of going through the
whole qbr it would be looking at the
questions and answers correct absolutely
um so first of all
do we have questions on the financial
budgetary element of the qbr
for David whilst he's here
and which have not been posed in a
written form beforehand
a lot of it is something and you you
will hear it several times because if
you if you come and sit in on on the
back of CNR you'll hear it the similar
presentations and you'll get similar
presentations
at full Council as well but um
especially
David's attempt to actually put a little
bit of Forward Thinking reality on
things and that last slide of actually
saying don't take the figures as they
are because this is what's in the wind
in the future
um very important and often we can't
can't predict precisely what's going to
happen but giving us full warning as to
what figures into especially in terms of
income and expenditure we can depend on
in the future and which we can't depend
on because they're one-off or whatever
and we're still financially we're still
in
um pretty weird times with this
post-pandem pandemic and we're seeing
the
um the income as it's actually turned
out to be to the council for these
burden payments as they as they refer to
them which is government paying us to do
the government's business of handing out
money Etc uh we're finding that
obviously our costs have been an awful
lot less than what we've been paid for
but we need to make sure that that
doesn't as a result skew our view when
looking at it it's it's one-off money
and it's not going to be there running
into the future
Wendy you had a question
obviously we've got
whatever Millions it was in reserves and
there is always an interest
your own interest in the normal way of
things would that just what happens to
that interest is that interest part of
what is the budget to be used or does
that go back into reserves to make the
reserves bigger
do you see what time
no no it's probably once isn't it
actually I asked you have questions oh
let me just go back a bit so
interest rates go up and down yeah if I
knew how they were going up and down up
wouldn't you sit here they'd be on a
yacht in the Mediterranean because I
would have had some money and made money
so as a council we do set a budget for
what income we're going to expect from
our short-term treasury deposits and
it's the same as Center budget for my
salary
yeah so if the the more it means it
offsets overspends elsewhere
and that Surplus and renting at the
start they that 833 pound surface half a
million the contribution to that came
from the fact that we had a very low
budget or income from interest rates and
we've vastly exceeded that and that just
means that we've got money in the
council coffers as a whole and community
and resources will determine how to
allocate that 830 000 pound Surplus so
it doesn't go into Reserve directly it
goes into a pot and then CNR will decide
where it goes so see now we'll have
various proposals put to about how we'll
use the Surplus as a whole
the Surplus from the charts to
interpretive Investments is one of the
contributory factors as to why we had a
surplus at all
um so just to give you some content we
had a budget I think probably 30 000 for
income from interest rates for this year
we virtually got no money from interest
rates in the financial year 2021-22 so
we've gone from no I'm getting about 100
barter to basically nothing
to half a million so that's obviously a
big movement so it doesn't it will
ultimately any surplus ends up in a
reserve but that Reserve is determined
by community and resources
thank you Doug
thank you chair
um this has probably been covered in the
past but as a new counselor
um
the amount of money that was transferred
from reserves into the the main funding
is more than was actually
needed to make the the budget stand now
I presume that then became effectively
working capital
to keep the to keep all the funds afloat
and then if there is a reserve if
there's any left over it could go back
into the uh into reserves could it idea
probably just to give you some context
as I saw a slide there we've had over 16
million pounds in in marked Reserves so
when in September you go remember
September interest rates hadn't started
their exponential rise we didn't know
about the issue with the council tax
Annex Grant where we've been sharing it
yeah and also a temperature
accommodation was on a
exponential increase
so if we went back in time we've made
like I said we maybe not have done that
however it was probably Good
Housekeeping anyway because there's
money that was sat in reserves I'd been
there for several years and the original
purpose for it
it'd probably become redundant
in a sense it's going back into Reserve
anyway because it's contributed into a
surplus it'll just be going into
different reserves that community and
resources allocate but it did look back
in September that it was problematic
that the council was going to balance
these books the other Factor play was I
said there was 464 000 pounds of
unbudgeted government grants we
never I've got to be careful because I'm
trying to remember a figure and I'm not
quite sure that it's that figure but I
think we've got to figure over a hundred
thousand pounds for what they call Post
payment verification work on covid
grants from previous years that's
basically us digging out who we'd paid
sending the information back to
government
we didn't incur a hundred thousand
pounds worth of costs on that we
incurred pressure on one officer within
the finance department maybe one officer
in the business rates team
you know so that was a win far to the
council which we didn't know at that
time so in reality the half million it's
no bad thing to look at the reserves and
check that this they've still got the
original purpose because time sometimes
moves on
I'm going to move
Peter yeah go and then
you can do if it's shortened to the
point
righteousness
can we leave that until we get into the
that that end of the qubit sorry we're
just doing the the the the the the
finance end at the moment and then we'll
move into it I'm going to go straight
into the questions which have been posed
in because the first two were Finance
anyway
um and
um the agenda page 13. are you able to
um because you're able to to put that up
on the screen
which would be
which is qbr uh as produced on the
agenda
they're on the on the supplement on your
iPad the question and answers is an
extra supplement I've got the questions
I want the actual qbr on the page that
they they relate to otherwise you're
just asking people to imagine a blank
piece of paper
you see where I'm coming from
yeah
because you have to go
to garage house
and okay I mean the the what I want you
to have in front of you is actually the
cute the qbr
um rather than the questions I can write
I can I can read out the questions you
need to be able to see what the question
related to
um
fine we'll we'll refine that for next
time
um going through the questions the first
questions from
um Mr Harper on budget narrative uh was
uh Native surplus of 833 000 will this
be returned to the reserves and the
response from David was yes it will go
to CNR for approval are you happy with
that Ian and again from Mr Harper
um on community agenda page 15.
um
with regard to Barton House included his
Sully house and units to be shown and
the Sully house hasn't the answer was
Sully house hasn't opened as at the
close of the financial year which is why
it's not there
um you have a follow-up on that I see it
coming
obviously there's expenditure in Sully
house this year
is that shown
yeah I know we also showed up well I
suppose Barton House is revenue isn't it
the refurbished yet
I don't think we've incurred the
expenditure Barton house refilter I
think is in the capital program I don't
believe it's been incurred last year I
could be wrong I was done to be
corrected
Surly house we purchased in
2022-23 and we incurred the expenditure
on the pods at Scarlet house in 2003 but
there is no income from somebody else
because it hasn't been converted to a
hustle yet and there's hot and the pods
were not occupied at the end of the
financial year
I've not answered your question
obviously so lots of questions
obviously what I wanted to look at was I
know do we actually show the capital
expenditure for them for Council and
where is that shown because obviously
there's an expenditure for Surly house
and also I assume there's a revenue cost
as well of actually converting it I know
you say you have it hasn't been
converted as such but there's still work
being going on the revenue costs will be
part of the capital program for the
conversion they'll be treated as capital
will they yes oh right
yeah
because it's what's the difference
between that and building it from
scratch really in a sense because it was
an office block and it's being converted
into hostile accommodation so that will
be uh the capital program and that's how
it that's it where it is so the
expenditure will be in the capital
she on the capital page of the qbr
that's where the expenditure would be
right love it thank you
right moving on with the um questions
posed on the the qbr
um again from and we're into local
economy this is under theme one
um
so we can't get that up on the screen no
okay don't worry about it I thought that
the agenda was pre-loaded
it's part of the agenda it's part of the
agenda it's not I'm not looking for
anything different I'm looking for the
it's part of the agenda
um with the
okay don't worry right
um I apologize that you you you can't
see it fully in context so anyway so
look local economy
um we've got a question concerning the
Apple door clean Maritime
um
in saying encouraging that interest
being shown indication of the actual
levels and response that you can see
from Chris Fuller Economic Development
officer
um which points out working through an
agency and that
um there is considerable interest
um although scale at this time is still
to be
um determined
happy though
um again supportive business and local
economy
um
whilst behind Target with the actions in
place could could these be given and
again Chris Fuller uh gives his reply
there
um and um
the various things that he lists up
right okay yes so if you can try to keep
um
Pace with us we're on theme one okay
and
um
I've never got
um no problems yeah
um
so
the next one again uh from uh on theme
one Economic Development uh torrage of
32 child poverty then measure by
percentage of mean earnings which has
been done to address this
um
and it's been poor for several the Chris
Fuller's response
um
you can see that
best way out is is higher earning
employment for all
um long-term piece of work on track to
achieve
and um
an example being the Apple door clean
Maritime Innovation Center
um Northern Devon Futures board we
collaborate with children and young
people group
who have specific focus on that thread
theme two please
yeah gone
in
with this
this has been a problem we've got for
quite a number of you well not a number
of years a large number of years
um and we just
what I really like to see sometimes from
the
the development of the economic
development is actually we do an awful
lot of
programs and projects be nice to see if
those actually achieve anything is it
measurable and what are the measurements
and actually are we achieving anything
by it because clearly at the moment
we're not really achieving anything and
yes the clean Maritime cleanly um
Innovation Center is great but that's
certainly going to be one small sector
the rest of it if you look at the rest
of the statistics and the uh the ons and
the census for the for torrage it's
absolutely poor we are an ash right down
at the very bottom
with child poverty now 32 and that's
probably one of the worst ones in Devon
um we go on forever and not all day on
it you look at it the education and the
qualifications are poor compared to
everybody else it's looking at how do we
actually bring that for the rest of the
people rather than yes it's important to
have the Innovation Center that's going
to be one small sector yeah the other
problem you've got as well and it was
actually pointed out by petrol is that
the people who or the young people who
have the the the education actually move
on and go outside the area and don't
necessarily come back how do we retain
those people and perhaps those are sorts
of things that torrage ought to be
looking at and understanding how do we
retain that chief executive was going to
comment on that
um thanks chair thanks Mr Harper so it
references Northern Devon Futures in the
in the response from from Chris Fuller
so that's a strategic partnership
working across Northern Devon so with my
shelf uh chief executive North Durban
represent the leaders representing the
the members petroch uh Sean mcnees the
chair of that partnership there's people
from Devon County Council major
businesses across the patch and one of
the key things we were talking about at
the the last workshop and we'll have a
look at the strategy in the vision is
ensuring we've got some baseline data
and data set so we can measure all the
things both councils and other
organizations are doing to improve the
overall you know the overwhelm
overwhelming problems in the area so
around skills education wage level rules
Health inequalities so across a range of
things that affect the area and as I
said councilor James the leader of the
council is sits on that board as well
once
um moving on theme two please uh Cassie
thank you
um uh communities health and housing
um again from Mr Harper
um
disabled facility grants could
explanation be given as to why there's
no information for this year the
response there from Stacey Dory head of
legal and government
um
current currently working alongside
foundations uh in respect of simplifying
their current policy
um and um
I said she gives a detail there
um I'm not going to read it all out
there will be further reports later in
the year to council
um
and as she points out that the
end-to-end time
um
varies greatly dependent on on what it
is that's been uh requested
and some things require structural work
some things are more simple to fix
um
and also the fact that much of the work
there requires tendering and Contracting
um because it basically it involves
construction and that again as we all
know
um
can delay
um happy with that in we thank you
moving on again uh temporary
accommodation
which is
n156 next page I should think
um
identified as an issue numbers High
rough estimate given for this year
of which the answer from again Stacey
Dory is no we can't give an estimate
um because there's no way of identifying
presentations that come through the door
in that sense and that is part of the
issue with this
um
and um so that they work with customers
as soon as they become threatened with
homelessness in a prevention role
and as we know the difficulty lack of
affordable accommodation to move move
people to
the local Housing Authority rates
haven't increased for a substantial
period
whereas rents have have gone up
um
Peter you've got a question on that
um there's a couple of questions in
there so uh we're always trying to
acquire private sense private sector
leasing accommodation so we're always
advertising and requesting liaison with
landlords to bring forward that type of
accommodation in terms of Sally house
the the pods are on site so that that
work had been ongoing and work has now
started on Sally house so I know last
week when I was up there on the
scaffolding was all up around the the
building so Works has started
um so we'll I think the time frame for
getting the work complete in and
occupied is September so there's a
program of works that need to be done
internally and externally to get the the
site ready
um in terms of acquiring other sites
other accommodation
um yes we've got additional funding from
government however that only provide 40
percent of the costs so the council
would have to match for match it with
the the other sixty percent to make it
up to 100 and we'll be bringing a report
to full Council setting out some options
uh for doing that shortly
um no the the Sally how the pods are on
site I'm not sure if we got a date for
them to be actually occupied yet
I'm not too sure the building works on
this main site interferes on I don't
know I know they've baked they're
installed and I think they're pretty
much ready to go as far as I understood
Jeff I just respond to that obviously
there's been difficulty over the last
couple of years and still exists now in
getting contractors in to do works and
we're reliant on external contractors to
do those those works I think
particularly with the
um groundworks I think we only ended up
with one uh contractor providing a quote
so it the market is strained and you
know
we have to do Works to it to make it
suitable for to be accommodated
worth pointing out that as we I think as
we know that the the level of works that
have to be done to these buildings for
people to be accommodated where in
effect we have duty of care
um is far superior to what we may
actually require or in our own
in our own houses and therefore it takes
just longer I mean hence my question
some time ago when Jan was here of what
why can't we use mobile
um mobile Caravans because they don't
meet the necessary standards as laid
down
um and and that type of thing so I can
imagine that there's a lot there's a lot
of work going but work is in progress I
mean you know when uh presumably working
to a plan
um fine thank you
um also under affordable housing
um well sorry also under this affordable
housing if we could have that back up uh
Kirsty please thank you
um
the
at the bottom number of affordable house
houses delivered
n155 well below
um and you know again
um
we continually have this issue that we
state it should be 30 percent
um one of the I can say I know that one
of the issues is that affordable housing
invariably is not actually signed off or
built and towards the end of a
development and therefore you may start
to have delivery of houses but you don't
you don't have delivery of the
affordable element until the development
is actually completed I know that's
happening in my neck of the woods where
I'm at the moment
the answer from Helen Smith planning
manager also says that we are short of a
post in that area Council housing
enabling
um council's housing enabler whose role
amongst other things will be to capture
and collate data in that area so
we we have a a a weakness there at the
moment that we're we're not able to
capture we
um
and saying that our our ability to fully
record record this until that post is
filled will be limited
um
do we have any other view on that or not
it's um chair in any addition to that
show we've approved the the the
um recruitment for that role um it's
just going through our internal
processes of job evaluation and so forth
before it can be advertised and that
will be done shortly okay thanks
um moving on to theme four
um our Council
well done that there we are and uh this
is bv012
on page 33.
there we go uh so bv012
um
from Mr Harper again number of long-term
sicknesses have nearly doubled from last
year
uh is this related to current
Marketplace issues uh and surveys the HR
manager uh responds there
uh she says there is an error in the
calculation with the figures provided in
the commentary
um
figures in the commentary again right
hand side
there's been a decrease in the number of
long-term sickness absences
um
from 30 in 21 22 to 23 in 22-23
accounting for 4.6 percent of all
absences
she says that in order to support staff
who are long-term sick we've introduced
employee assistance program in September
last year
which offers employees fast access to
counseling and number of support guides
um managing all she says to actively
manage all sickness cases and use an
occupational health provider to give us
advice how to manage individuals health
conditions in the workplace
um
and I I can from personal example or
experience
know that um
the the department does actually pursue
and maintain and closely monitor
sickness
and I was involved a couple of years
back where um
somebody was being followed up on quite
carefully and
you happy that at the moment
moving on end of year summary on pages
37 and 47 to 30 40 37 47 question from
Stephen dengate who's not here today
under complaints on le260
right there we are
um
increasing Trend upwards on complaint
processing time for second year is this
due to nature of complaints becoming
more complicated or the resources to
handle them
and again Sarah as said
um
they've had several very comp several
very complex cases to deal with last
year which took longer than the agreed
deadline of 28 days to conclude
um
there are occasions where thorough
investigation is preferential to a
quicker response in especially in cases
which might later be referred to the
local government ombudsman
delays in most cases not significant but
because case numbers are relatively low
just one or two can significantly skew
the average
um
and then she goes on to say that recent
staff movements
um within teams or people leaving the
council meant that some experiencing
complaint case management has been lost
as we know the the usual issues with
churn in the workplace and the the loss
of experience
and she talks about a training event
coming up
um in September and
um
and new officers for torridge and that
will hopefully
expand the pool of complaint handlers
again from Stephen dengate
Human Resources again uh BB 102
um
sickness Trends seem to be increasing
which must be impacting overall
um
sorry
I did have my hand raised I'm sorry I
didn't question about the complaints go
on then right
um You said at the beginning of this
meeting that the development of the qbr
framework might require some tweaking
now is this issue one that needs to be
considered as to rather than showing
things as a percentage
because a percentage of two is 55 and it
looks really appalling should we be
looking at the numbers as uh complaints
thank you as opposed to the percentages
and I would suggest that there might
have been a reason for it
but for me
um when you don't know and I think Sarah
alludes to the fact that some have been
complex so I think it would be helpful
to actually know I think that's a very
very valid point though thank you it's
the appropriate method of quantifying
online by line so or some things
a percentage will be appropriate yes
other things actually more appropriate
that it's actually uh by figure and
that's a very good point Clara thank you
um
have you got that one John
I apologize for not picking up you need
to
like throw half your glasses at me
um okay
um
so this was a continuation really of the
human resources and sickness question
again from Stephen dengate
um
and um
and
Sarah answers that by saying that the
the the the the commentary the the
Figures were were was there was an error
in the calculation in the figures
um
moving on again to housing n156
again from Stephen dengate that will be
the uh moving on please here we are
and the second one down
um
indicators suggest rental market options
will continue to decrease with the uh
likely increasing cost for attainable
rental properties
this has become our largest statutory
overspend hours reinforced by David
earlier
um
how long can torridge manage this
significant cost before it impacts on
our overall Financial resilience very
good question
um
and their status response
we obviously recognize the impact is
having on the budget
um and we need to reduce the spend as
soon as possible
um
in part she says we don't have control
over it but I would say
but it is a fact that that that that
that is going to come crashing into us
more as a sledgehammer especially as the
one-off or exceptional areas of income
drop away that David was alluding to
earlier
um
this
huge cost will have an even greater
um uh impact on us
um
there's no I mean other than saying yes
conscious yes come on
no I'm just saying it's she's
strategy because I mean it this is this
is
all into interlinked yes chair and it's
part part of what I just explained a
short while ago about the report coming
back with the the options they have to
be funded as well so there's funding to
save expenditure and we've got a deter
and Council have got to determine
whether uh you're willing to put that
Capital funding in to increase our
available stock of temporary
accommodation
um obviously we don't know how long our
will and the country will be in this
position because as the question
indicates and as we know private rentals
sector accommodation is struggling with
mortgage rates going up and people in
that market are now starting to sell
property so you know
we do in what we're able to do in a
market that a significant problem
it must yes
I wonder if we can just hear from from
David what a worst case scenario might
be if they're sort of spiral out of
control well I'd probably go back a
stage is we created a member budget
working group in recognition of this and
the member budget working group made
took some tough decisions in terms of
raising income from say car parking Etc
um the impacts of let's just say doubled
we were paying two million pounds out it
does depend on all the other factors I
already mentioned that we're probably
going to make half a million on
temporary Investments that would negate
it but when you give yourself doubled
then clearly a very harsh decisions
would have to be made you know you're a
member load Authority we've got a member
but we'll have a member budget working
group there to make decisions on the
budget it's more overexpended she would
have to give but what Steve said we're
making a lot of efforts to minimize it
when I first started maybe only
three four years ago we maybe had four
PSL five PSL properties with close
coming up to 20. it's still a cost but
it certainly mitigates the cost of
temperature accommodation
will probably within 12 months have
doubled
the amount of hostile accommodation from
when I started maybe even a little bit
more than that we've reaching out the
High Street we're going for
solar house and maybe Huddleston Road as
well so that and the more we do the
modular accommodation that'll mitigate
some of the expenditure the truth is it
is a big Financial pressure to the
council when you say stays can't
actually answer it because we don't know
we don't know I mean it the last it has
flattened you know we're honestly we're
on a very high Plateau but it has
plateaued for now
we don't case numbers are fairly static
the cost of accommodation temp
accommodation is
flat it's not a good flat because it's
massively above where we originally
budgeted only a couple of years ago
yeah and just at the back first Ken yes
amazing
foreign
I've just taken up the gauntlet of lead
member for this area so I have been
doing a little bit of research and
looking at things which I think had is
good to advise this committee about what
is happening
we have had a growing number of
successful allocations through our
choice-based lettings scheme addressing
the needs of our clients which is is
really good there seems to be a bit more
movement which means people which mean
people are actually getting permanent
homes
um I urge caution with regard to private
sector lease properties
because it's not just a question of
having another a roof it's a question of
maintaining that property and the
associated costs with that which can
bite you in the proverbial so I think we
need to be cautious about that one of
the emerging things that I think we need
to be alert to is mortgage interest
rates and the pressures that is going to
put on some households some households
that may not have experienced that kind
of pressure before so that we make sure
that our advice services are readily
available to them to assist them in
talking to their mortgage providers
because again they may not know how to
go about this so I would like to see
some kind of active marketing of what to
do if you're concerned about not meeting
your mortgage payments rather than the
head in the sand until you've got a
Monumental debt and then it's to it's
almost too late so it's not going to be
right tomorrow that people are going to
be in trouble with their mortgages but
you give it six months
you could see a considerable number of
people defaulting if the can if we don't
get inflation down and prices continue
to rise and the cost of living is still
an issue so those are the things some of
the things I should be looking at with
the service
um who are the leaders who's the lead in
signposting towards
um people getting into
restructuring debt or restructuring
mortgage Etc Citizen's advisor when the
PBS yeah yeah
devices sorry
there's only about a 25 or 30 response
rate
um
that's good but there is nationalized
there as well but I don't think it's
interesting
last week
we're going to increase
people on various mortgages
it's an average solution
higher than that and those that have a
little deposit will be paying a higher
mortgage you need to remember we have
little wages in Norwich which is a
situation that we're facing anyway and
you're also learning
mortgage
food and fuel
it says
I think
I think 100 single-player mortgages in
charge uh 30 percent owners and I think
uh there's supposed
centers there and if you get another 20
out of fifteen hundred
that's going to be a significant number
to Europe
yeah yeah
uh just sort of to add to the list that
councilor Pennington has said that the
food bank does now have a financial
advisor and I believe that sort of debt
is covered within that when you might
tell me if it's not but um
sorry that's all right just to say that
you know as a food bank we have sort of
recognizing that the potential there for
for debt to be a significant problem as
interest rates continue to rise
from the
people clearly are aware of the the
potential uh down track and that's the
most important thing that people are
talking about it and and and are are in
part preparing for it okay
um we need to move on
um
looking to Legal Services uh this is
le262
um
there we are in the middle
um Freedom of Information requests
um
basically
um Stephen asking uh are
um
is this operating within acceptable
levels
um
and Stacy Dory comes comes back and says
that there's no indication at the moment
that there's um there's any
increase in capacity required but it is
being kept
um under review
um
numbers are as you can see are
slightly up on last year but
um
not exponentially
again moving on to property
climate change view of the the efforts
in reducing emissions from Target
Council operations is there a specific
Factor courting the upward Trend or is
it due to increased operations
um there's a good point and the uh Donna
Sibley joint climate change officer
responds there
basically reasons being greater
expenditure on Goods which due to the
spend method used to calculate a bit
technical
spend method used to calculate scope 3
emissions inflates the carbon footprint
um
and secondly an increase in the carbon
footprint for our operational Services
basically they've been busy and they've
been driving more
um
Etc that first point greater expenditure
on Goods which due to the spend method
used to calculate scope 3 emissions
inflates the carbon footprint anybody
can have a go at decoding that
foreign
yes uh sort of a scope three is
obviously the amount of emissions that
is uh basically produced in creating the
items in the first place so it's not the
amount of emissions that we have from
using it it's the amount of embodied
emissions in the purchase of the icon so
we are purchasing more things which have
taken great amounts of carbon to produce
in the first place yeah
I do say a um
yeah Scott I mean afternoon you don't
necessarily know the full carbon cost of
an item so you're often running off just
an average so uh we might actually be
preparing stuff that is less carbon
intensive than the average but we
wouldn't necessarily know yeah yeah
as James said invariably the information
may not be there in the first place
chair this kind of links in with the
next item a social value because I think
it's all interconnected with the new
procurement rules and then
um
the next question which was the
recycling
um and um the um we're on to
um the room
total recycling there so our our
recycling is very marginally in
percentage terms uh down
um
and he talks about Garden waste has been
trending down since over the last few
years is there a correlation to our
increasing charges or
on this or have these correlations
remained equivalent collections remained
equivalent and
um
there of course we're talking tonnage so
we are actually talking
um uh sort of actual rather than
percentage and things and it's down
slightly here's the answer from Richard
haste is
um
introducing a chargeable service has
seen tonnages reduce into since
implementation in 2018 the cost of
living increases may also have
contributed to slight decline in
addition to the weather which also plays
its part on the amount we collect last
year's six-week dry spell saw tonnages
drop considerably
um
The Authority estimates a 30 take up
with the service which is on par with
other authorities across the country and
we are still achieving this rate
um
and there he gives the uh the the the
tonnages which we know because we can
see from this anyhow and and um
and the total number of
um
bins as well uh um bin numbers
it's a quite a significant drop off in
that when when you get into that the hot
time
yes indeed uh it may be uh quite helpful
if we also had the volume because
obviously in hot weather being that
green materials 90 of the way is the
moisture in it
um obviously we've got high high
temperatures that could be a substantial
reduction in the amount of weight but
very little reduction in the amount of
volume that's being collected
very true I didn't know whether I don't
know how easily such data could be
collected and whether it would be
but I know we're coming from yeah
um Doug I think the same thing applies
to things like cardboard if you speak to
any farmer and he's putting green into a
silo he always wants it to be dry when
he said no he wants it to be wet when
you're setting it sorry okay
but I think the moisture is a very valid
track here a very valid point so it'll
skew the it'll skew the figures if
you're collecting wet cardboard the
collectors always prefer it wet it's
easier to handle
but then the tonnage will will go up I
think it's more just an understanding
that actually
um
in a peculiar sense in the height of the
summer when it's hot often the the
amount goes down and with people without
giving it a thought might think the
amount will go up but actually if you
consider that the growing seasons of May
and September
um that's when you know there's going to
be the the the the the bulk or in the in
in this spring on the Autumn okay
um
that and the
the formal questions on the qbr and I
just again going back to our sort of
initial tutorial or introduction
um I just hope that that demonstrates
that you can get you can get more depth
on it by posing a question early and
therefore we've got all sorts of
officers there who've been able to to
answer something in detail
um and um
we have the opportunity if we're not
happy with something or we want to
monitor something that John will capture
it and put it on our action list so it
will then we will then ask for an update
or for some action to be taken on it and
in the next meeting we will then look at
the action list and see what's been done
or not
um uh and um so it's important that and
John is so quietly kept capturing things
there that we um
we may want to see again in the future
okay
moving on uh uh that is that is the end
of um uh the qbr4 we labored it slightly
this morning because um we're just
wanting to to explore the the value of
it and just see how it works
um
item 10 on the agenda social value
update from the
from you John yes that's you thank you
um just a little bit of background for
the for the new members
um
the task and finish group was set up
during the last committee period
um to look at social value and to to see
if we needed our own social value policy
we had two task and finish meetings one
included a training session with the
procurement manager of Exeter city
council which went down very well we had
another one just kind of a scoping and
an ideas
um of how we think which we should be
going
um there is a little
um
kind of ongoing issue that why we
haven't gone further with this is that
the government are producing a local
public sector procurement bill
and that procurement bill is going to
put a emphasis on
social value within that and the idea
was there was no point in US drafting
something before the bill was in place
we'd wait for the bill to make sure that
we aligned with actual the legislative
requirements that was coming out of it
so the bill the proposals of the bill
are to move award from criteria based on
price to include considerations of
social value public benefit well-being
and suitability
uh it's going to create a single Central
platform for contract data and
registration
it's going to introduce a new process
for emergency buying and crisis
procurement
an established timelines for
transparency notice with a procurement
review unit able to investigate concerns
around awards and transparency so that's
kind of the background of work where it
is as of last Tuesday
the procurement Bill had its report
stage and third reading in the House of
Commons
it is now going back to the House of
Lords
for peers to consider the commons
amendments
now one of the Amendments is around the
creation of a National Security National
Security unit for procurement which will
proactively investigate suppliers for
National Security threats
um and they will publish within six
months of the passing a bill a timeline
for the removal of all surveillance
equipment provided by suppliers subject
to National Intelligence law
of China from sensitive government sites
so it's a wide-ranging build there's
lots going on there is going to be a
requirement for social value
we as I said just now we set up a task
and finish group there's only two
members last left of the task and finish
group the chair and Mr Dan gate
so my suggestion to to the committee is
that I think we probably need to set up
a new group
so that we can
take stock
it's coming quite quickly now of what
we're going to get from the procurement
bill so we can start looking at drafting
a social value policy for the council
there are plenty of examples out there
um
the procurement officer and
joint climate change officer are looking
at some software as well because
actually having a policy in place is
great but I didn't monitor it how do you
measure it and that gets really
complicated and like I see you
understand
um and the bit that I quite I I didn't
understand is although
the spend
of the social value side of side of it
um
you might go and say well we give to a
national charity or we do something up
in where our thing is based actually
what's coming out of this is the actual
social value has to be seen in the area
to which the spend occurs
you can't no so that's getting a little
bit more complicated how do you measure
how do you monitor
um
so my suggestion chair is and it's
something that's been on your forward
plan for for a while is to set up a new
small group of councilors who are
interested in meeting and then we can we
can have another little
um kind of training session so that
we're all on the same page and then
start looking at drafting a a social
value policy that we can bring to the
committee and then take it on to if it's
CNR and full Council or whatever it is
uh
the actual I agree with that that we
need to reset the working group
um and the composition of that working
group we won't deal with hair because
missing so many members at the moment uh
I will
discuss with a membership of the
committee uh
on on email and we we will look for
areas of interest to start with and see
whether we've got people who are very
very particularly Keen to Doug yes
um but uh thank you for that
um
any other questions on
fiendishly from what we looked at
um in the two sessions that we had
especially with subject matter experts
coming and speaking to us
hugely difficult area to to really
really difficult and it and it
your view
varies from your view varies from your
view as to what is important and and
that's that's one of the problems is
that it's it's so subjective
um dependent on who you are what your
interests are what your values are Etc
very very difficult to to pin down so
it'll be fascinating to see what comes
out at the higher level
um and how that drives us
we will address we will put together a a
separate group for it and we will start
afresh because um it obviously
no longer relevant
the ones we had uh good thank you John
um
hahaha
annual report
this is the report on the last
committees a year which
John and Kirsty have put together uh my
name is on it but I I was only a member
of ons for part of the year and it is
it is a a factual summary of what the
committee did rather than necessarily
um expressing a view on anything I'm not
going to read through it but if you
hopefully you've already looked at it
and um
is there any
comment
on it
check and I just say I I it is a cons in
the Constitution that we um
producer an annual report which year and
I believe it might have to go to full
Council I believe that's the case I
can't remember for sure but so it would
be good if if the committee could vote
to accept it if they are happy with it
so that we have a formal process then
whether or not it does need to go to
full counts or if it just needs to be
accepted here and and circulated to
members in another way and we must be
presumably we must be reporting to
somebody in terms of an annual report
whether it's
or not um Chad I think it was something
that was brought up and considered
during the lashed Council and deemed
that it would be a good uh thing to do
to report to the wider members uh the
work of the committee you'll check
whether the Constitution requires you to
go to full Council or whether it's uh
simply circulated to all members or put
in the bulletin but I guess if you've
approved it then we can do as necessary
and John can discuss that with you
um after the meeting yeah thank you so
to that end I agree we we will be
submitting our report to full Council
they can handle it however is deemed
right
have you got a point in
I wasn't going to make a point I was
going to propose it as being the only
person here that actually was there all
the time it reflects accurately what we
did last year are you happy that it is a
true reflection and having been there
for part of the time I will second it so
um and uh I mean we we can't ask
Community mem well
are you happy that we send send this
report to full Council I know that you
can't actually vouch for all the detail
in it because you weren't but the
principle of sending the annual report
from last year to fall Council that is
the thing if people could just show
their approval to that
good fun
you're happy with that stay there thank
you
uh now the a key thing for this
committee is to construct
um a good forward plan
um a because it keeps us on the rails in
terms of what we're looking at secondly
it gives people who are going to
contribute to that scrutiny time to
prepare a report and for for it to be
properly done
um
and I I want and that's why I asked um
John to put up the slide of what we'd
done in the past
um
Kirsty we've been able to go back to
that or not we're going to
um it is it's on the one when he gave
the the internal honest presentation
whilst Coast is finding that
obviously within our forward plan
the qbr appears at regular intervals uh
through it
and
also in there I've put
at the end at the end of the year you'll
see in cycle six in December 23
that we should do a review of the qbr
process I'm not talking about a major
review but that is where we would
capture any tweaks that we've we've
we've spied during the year and
formulate them into one and then and
also just just have a little bit of time
looking at the qbr saying is it all
actually delivering the information we
want in the way we want
um so putting a bit of formality into it
um
running back that's obviously what the
Committees looked at over the last four
years
um
firstly
those things which um
uh
uh the the the the the the obvious thing
is where do we put how soon can we put
the homelessness strategy in
okay I was discussing that with the
other officers this morning I think uh
if we just delayed a cycle to the
September meeting that will give us an
opportunity to work through what we need
in terms of a strategy and work with the
leader lead member so that's a key
that's obviously a key one at the moment
so let's slip homelessness into cycle
three into September
um
and then
what I want you to do and this is the
homework but because I'm not I'm not I'm
not planning to put anything into boxes
today
what I wanted to do it was to expose to
you the the
what has been done in the past
together with us all being refreshed
with the purpose of the committee and
and the scope of the committee
um and with that
and that knowledge
um I want people to to go away and
actually think through
what really
where they think we should be having a
look
and if it's within the bounds of the
council then we can look anywhere if
there is benefit and there is
justification for doing so
um
and um
areas that
I have
um
particularly
wanting to to look at one actually was
raised by councilor or was touched on by
councilor Pennington in full Council
last night
and
we have a number of
of areas of relief for for
people who live in the area whether it
be at the higher level
um
pension credit which is which is a a
thing outside of our our control as such
whether all the way down to household
support funding as part of the postcovid
Packages Etc
there is a huge amount of money out
there at the moment
and there's relatively very little
take-up of it and
um the
um
and as a as a counselor and I'm sure all
councils do exactly the same as a
counselor whenever
um they've been
um online advertisements produced
um sent out to us for the latest
household support Grant or whatever
I've always
copy that into the local Facebook groups
of each of my villagers who each have a
Facebook group Etc and I raise it at
local Parish Council meetings etc etc as
we all do
still the uptake is very very low
and as the lead member for um
Democratic services and uh and uh and
legal I also
um cover the revenues and benefits side
and I sign off on quite a lot of the the
household support ones Etc and there's
hardly any and
it's a real issue as to is it
communication issue
um
you
is it pride that people actually won't
put their hand up and say I need help
um is it because we've become such a
dysfunctional Society these days that we
don't know what our neighbor is up to
and therefore can't spot that our
neighbor is is is in hard times and
therefore can't put an arm around them
and say actually why don't you apply for
this
um it can be a multitude of things I
think it would be useful at some stage
to try to just sit down because
potentially there are areas where the
council if if it is an area where we
think is is failing or not necessarily
failing but where we could improve maybe
that communication could be better Etc
that is something that council could do
about it some of it may be just human
nature and we can't do anything about it
but there is masses of money out there
and people are just absolutely not
um taking it up
um and um and it's a concern
um
why are not people taking it up you're
gonna say something Cloud yeah I think
it's it's quite important that we
recognize that we have a lot of new
members and I'm not suggesting that
they're all not informed about all the
grants and issues but there will be a
lot that don't understand the criteria
that is set and the policy that is set
for applying to these things so we want
to be sure of what we're promoting so
that we fully understand it when we're
sharing that with people who might
benefit from those schemes because you
mentioned the household support fund
which is one slightly less complex
qualification to apply for that but the
benefit that was being referred to last
night was the hardship council tax and
that is you if you look at
deep dive into it it is quite complex so
I wonder if it would be helpful if uh
one of the officers could do us a
briefing
on you know what uh
the criteria is for making applications
to these so that we have a better
understanding or at least refer us
to because it is on our website
but sometimes you can read those things
and if it's not clear to us
it's certainly not going to be clear to
Joe public
so I would agree entirely Claire and
that that
whole debate when we get around to it
absolutely should be informed by
officers
saying what the the the criteria and
what the eligibility is what the what
the access is to some of these because
some as you say are easier than others
um and um uh the uh to The Other Extreme
you would like to councilor Pennington
who who Who's suggesting that
the number of people who could access
um pension credit who aren't uh are in
their hundreds
um uh and and we're talking about
significant amount of money potentially
you know
um
relief so and that's an area that we
need to become more informed in and then
try to understand
why there isn't a greater uptake in
certain areas one of it may be because
people aren't eligible because they're
not qualified because of the the the
rules that you vote rightly pointed out
you mentioned Joe um a number of reasons
I think they all apply I wouldn't pick
any one of them out particularly but I
think there are so many factors in there
and probably the greatest one is
publicity people just probably don't
know I'd hesitate to put that top of
them well that's why we would discuss it
exactly and it may be that as a result
of that we don't come up with anything
that we can we can recommend should be
done but I think it it it's a useful
exercise just to make sure sorry Claire
back again now
um yes I'm always very keen to know the
evidence base for some of these
quotations of how many people
um because I'm absolutely hopeless at
remembering numbers
um and having been lead member for
finance but I shouldn't be admitting now
but my recall for you know how how many
percent how many claim for this that and
the other I like to know where the
source is and whether this is
speculative or actually factual and wear
these figures because they can be so
emotive
to people I lay awake last night
thinking of the three people that the
counselor referred to that had no
electricity Supply
what happened to them did they get
referred to our household support fund
did they get a resolution
uh and that was the first thing I
actually asked him this morning
but no referral had been made for those
people
to the household support fund
so there was a missed opportunity there
although he's done some remarkable work
with regard to uh pension credits and
other aspects so it's having a suite of
um benefits that people can apply for
and making sure that we access them all
not just the ones we happen to know a
little bit more about right
thank you correct
um so that's one
um
I'd like to
at some stage have a better
understanding of the future Estates plan
with regard to active torrage
active Tory job
will be reporting to full Council
when they do
they report to external scrutiny on the
the work that active storage do in terms
of the funding they receive similar to
what we were talking about earlier
around the plow so because they're
funded an accident
but are they an external organization
there are a separate company to the
council it's just that the council owns
it so it's I had a discussion with the
LGA last week or earlier this week and
they were suggesting it
could be internal
and whichever I have the we own the
property that that is the vehicle on
which active torrage set and therefore
that is actually our business because it
concerns the future estate strategy
um and uh I I think we should ask to see
the figures with regard to the forward
delivery of the estate I.E what we own
um uh uh which is not passed to the
ownership of active torrage is it
um no chair so the the property team of
Torres manage the buildings
um active storage under contract with
storage Council occupy the buildings so
if there's anything to be done to the
buildings that's a torrage council
decision so active toys wouldn't be able
to
I didn't knock down the internal walls
and create a new what I well I think
what at some stage because
the the performance of active torrage is
not it is not in question particularly
uh and and you know I'm sure we will get
an upbeat presentation when they come
the one area that has been of concern to
councilors throughout is actually the
the
long-term viability of the estate that
we're actually using to operate active
Tory John namely those buildings and you
know we are potentially
um
and I'm not trying to I don't want to be
funny on this area but there is there is
a there is a fun potentially a
fundamental Financial issue there in
that we we are running on buildings some
of which are considered possibly to be
lifeed already which in time will no
longer become will have to do something
with so
if we're going to look at active
torridging around properly we need to
actually look at the the estate side of
it as well
um chair that that's already been at
full comes if you remember so we've got
Asset Management strategy and
underpinning that's an action plan to
look at all assets within the council's
estate and councilors agreed an approach
for determining the future let's speak
let's be quite clear though full council
is not where scrutiny takes place and
and in that sense I and just because
something comes to fall Council I don't
believe that actually it it has been
properly scrutinized and I I look
forward
to seeing a detailed business plan that
includes the estate and how we're going
to continue to manage and provide that
estate at what predicted cost going
forward for 10 20 years whatever because
it it otherwise it'll be a showstopper
and
um that's what I you know I'm not being
not not being funny over it and active
torrage as an operational company is
fine and it's all good news
um but but there's potential in Achilles
heel in the estate it's we're having to
work on is
um
has issues
history has does the the whole council
at the state well yeah
so that sort of thing
um sorry yeah
um I think you know going back to your
initial uh statement about this
situation
there are several issues that arise for
the council that could quite easily sit
in external or internal
and I think uh it was mentioned actually
at external scrutiny
by the the vice chair
why aren't we having just one scrutiny
committee and I think everybody went oh
um we've tried that before and it didn't
work
but there are occasions where the
interests of both scrutiny committees
uh
focused on a single entity and I think
we need to look at our constitution or
seek advice as to whether we could have
joint scrutiny
both committees over certain key
issues and I think that would actually
resolve this problem of is it mine or is
it yours oh you're full of wisdom today
um
[Laughter]
is there any reason why I could not
agree with the chair of ons external
that we're going to hold a joint session
uh chair we've done it we have done it
before and just going back a loop and we
had the the Constitution constitutional
working group that was one of the
considerations to move to a single
scrutiny committee which most most
councils operate because it avoids all
this all this confusion and there's no
requirement to have two scrutiny
committees but obviously as Council
Hudson measure when the suggested was
like oh no that's
but you know there's those two options
to consider I I like that I mean as you
rightly pointed out both sides have an
interest in something like
um the the the active towards side and
that may well be best handled in a in a
joint session
yeah the uh and further to that
dependent on how that works there might
be uh a change of will we have a new
Council
um to actually consider those things uh
there are those that feel that perhaps
we wouldn't be able to go the meetings
would have to be more frequent because
you'd have much bigger agendas if you
merge the Committees together but you'd
only be servicing one committee and I
think that's something when we're
looking strategically at our priorities
perhaps that's something we ought to be
having on the table for our vision for
uh 20 23 to 20 however long I've got
eight
I would never
underestimate the
importance and the percentage of this
committee's work in monitoring the qbr
which is the key performance indicator
of of the council
um and um
that takes a lot of time if you go if
you went joint the whole time I know
well anyway I hear where you come from
but specifically on a subject like that
if we decided to put it want to do it
then that that that is something that
that would be well addressed being joint
because we'd then be looking at the
whole aspect of it
um because if you scrutinize something
but you're only interested in half of it
because the other half doesn't apply to
you you're not scrutinizing the whole
um it's still and we need to look at
everything that affects first of all
from our point of view our money
um our taxpayers money
um and um then also obviously the the
value that the service is providing
which is more external
thank you um yes I remember the the
conversation very well and one of the
other things that came up was lightening
the load on any one of the Committees
because
um if we can do it we can go into more
depth if we do it individually but
there's no reason whatsoever that we
can't have a combined
um
if necessary it could be independently
scheduled if it was that important
anyway okay so I'm going to ask I'm
going to ask to um
uh due to look through the the the the
the back catalog of what this committee
has looked at
um and I also want you to bring to it
the the the fresh fresh thought uh
especially of new councilors without
being sort of oh well you know this is
the same old thing that we do and and so
on
um and
at the next
um meeting
um I would like to be able to
um
get to a stage when we can really
populate
um and get get some really good topics
in uh internet and it doesn't have to be
next month or the next month after that
it might be something that we're not
going to look at for for for for for for
six or or more months
um and where we can actually go and get
those those topics uh into it
um
that been the case
John is there anything that we've got at
the moment that um
we
other than doing our work program for
the next meeting scheduled on the 25th
of July
uh that's a very good question chair
um there's nothing that Springs to mind
before then unless you wanted to set up
your social value
um task and finish group or yeah put
that in there because we need to
formally set it up so put that in please
yeah um okay yeah
um one of the things that occurred to me
with this new wonderful portal we have
and I've been discovering all sorts of
bits of information the benchmarking
figures
now I don't know whether everybody's
aware of those and has looked at them
where they compare and contrast our
performance in our benchmarking group
it's not apples and well it's obviously
apples and pears but it's perhaps
different varieties of apples as opposed
to completely different fruit
um North Devon is included uh as well
and I wondered if that would be an
informative start for us looking at
things as to where we're not performing
well
where we're at the bottom of the scale
and whether that would actually focus
our minds on what we ought to be
bringing to
this this committee to consider because
in some places we're doing really well
others as we have mentioned about child
poverty all sorts of issues not so good
so sooner rather than later
it might be good to have an overview of
that and actually draw our attention and
focus on some key issues for setting our
forward plan I mean we need to make sure
that first of all all all
members are fully conversant and aware
of the
porting system
anyway in a sense
um
no just you know jump into something
that Mr Harper mentioned to me at the
beginning before the meeting started was
around the census data and benchmarking
for the new Committee just to get an
idea of the issues that the area does
face and also as as councilor Hudson
said about the performance against
others so it could be that you know we
put together the census report and the
show where the benchmarking information
is and and some key bits if that's what
members wanted as a kind of a baseline I
think that'd be that'd be very useful
actually right and
it's not only the census I'd actually
take the ons there's some very good
reports on those a particular auditorage
itself which is quite uh quite
Illuminating
um are we able to
um who would run with putting a report
uh
like that I mean yeah quite okay
you happy later
yeah okay yeah good that would be enough
um for um that's the other uh tendency
is don't put because there often will be
extra things that slip in anyway don't
start by trying to overload the forward
plan and from there we'll then hopefully
because of the next one is has got qbr
in it which will take up quite a
significant part of the meeting anyway
so that doesn't have to have too much
loading in it and from there we can then
flesh out
um with the subjects that we will
discuss
good
um I will back that up with an email to
all of the committee because people are
are not here today
um in terms of getting them to um think
through
subjects that we need to be looking at
um any other matters that um
I apologize for being slightly
disjointed as we've slightly found our
way with a couple of things uh and uh
but uh thank you very much indeed for
your
um attendance today and I uh close the
meeting
until we meet again whenever it is on
the
um
the 25th of July